the heart has very limited capacity for regeneration
after injury
and this is an increase cause
of uh human morbidity and mortality world wide
there is a compelling un-clinical need to
identify the opposite cell type to drive robust
cardiac muscle regeneration
because this uh very recent ah discovery actually
uh is
the latest in a chain of
scientific discoveries
and for the first it uh reports of
the identification
of the cell that could be viewed as perhaps
an optimal cell type
to promote cardiac muscle
uh regeneration
because the cells that have been isolated
have come from
embryonic stem cells
and than had been used to form an intact strip
functioning
ventricular muscle tissue
while you may start out with a very small
number of cells
they have the capability
to proliferate and then maintain their ability
to make muscle
and it's that property that makes a very unique
we decided to ask the question
how is the heart built in the first place
if you want to rebuild a broken heart
then go back and look at nature and find
out how it's done normally
so we went back to their embryo of mouse and
we essentially color coded the heart and were able
to pick up very specific populations of hearts cells
which have these unique qualities of being
able to replicate
and at the same time being completely committed
to the muscles heath aid
the cells turn out to have it built in clocks
in them
meaning when we isolate them they are capable
of of renewing for a while
but then after a certain period of time
they will stop reviewing and they would
made sure into functioning my cartel tissue
these are stem cells that are actually differentiating
the test tube and from them working to generate the hearts tissue
and using these cells and the tissue engineering
technology that was developed by a Kit parker
and Adam Feinberg over in the school engineering
we were able to generate two-dimensional mial cardial tissue
out of that
now to get to full cardiac regeneration we
need to get to the three dimensions but already
we've taken this huge step forward with respect
to regenerating the heart
and we've develop a platform that will allow us
to study how normal heart functions